[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad and what a coach and what
a butcher yes today i'm joined by a lad
of many talents he started off as a gun
rugby player playing for the tasman
marco bay of plenty the crusaders and
the chiefs before becoming one of the
best butchers on the planet and he's now
quickly climbing up the coaching rank
ranks as he's about to be the head coach
of the tasman marco for this year's
bunnings cup
it is one of the great lads dan piggy
perrin welcome mate cheers jimmy mart
thanks for the intro stoked to be here
mate looking at your top the butcher's
on you're ready to go the 19th warrior
mate how good was it to have them back
in town the other week and uh yeah
proudly rocking the butchers uh
top there so
representing how good but mate busy time
of the year for you um appreciate you
coming on the podcast
about to get stuck into the big busy
season with tasman marco um co-head
coach this year how's it been yeah it's
been awesome mate the lads have slowly
started rolling into town over the last
couple of weeks and uh
yeah we're just chipping away and
reconnecting with them and setting them
up for what's going to be an exciting
competition so you can't wait to hook in
really looking forward to it how hard is
it to sort of set up the season without
most of your team here while you're
while you're preparing
yeah i guess we're pretty lucky corny
and i have both been in the tessie
uh set up for a few years now so we know
how it rolls and yeah like you said
that's tough with them not being here
but uh they roll in the trainers are
doing a fantastic job reconditioning
them and uh in the two weeks that they
get with them and and uh yes just uh
they know the blueprint we roll into it
and get stuck in so yeah it's really uh
yeah they're just
like natural really and how's your job
changed from like last year or previous
years where you've been involved
yeah there's uh a little bit more
off-field stuff as a co-head coach you
know last couple years has been involved
in the set piece but getting alongside
corny and around the contracting and the
planning and uh around setting up our
team as well which uh you're into jimmy
mart so um just been setting all that up
really but uh like you said
uh we've been in the environment for a
few years now so we know how to set it
up and looking forward to it and a
couple of i guess big shoes to fill um
with shane christie and andrew goodman
the goat um i guess stepping away it
gives you guys an opportunity to step in
there but how do you feel around the
pressure of um filling those shoes oh no
pressure at all if anything the
pressure's a privilege you know and
they've set this club up really well and
um what they've done for for this union
over many years um i think has paved the
way for for coin and i to come in and
take take the reins and uh we had a real
good passing of the baton with goody at
the end of last year and start of this
year and um maddie's still heavily
involved there's still whatsapp messages
every day wanting to know what we're up
to so
that's good mate you know
he's passionate about the union and so
are we and we only want to see it
succeed so
they've done marvelous things and
they've set us up well to take it over
so yeah it's um you've been really
privileged to be to work with them over
the last few years too
clark dermody as well obviously he was
the year before where um it was probably
a bit more specific to your role but you
must have learned a little bit of him as
well yeah he's a great man derms and to
come in and do a bit of my
apprenticeship under him a couple of
years ago
learned a heap off him he's a
great uh character and a real student of
uh set piece play so
to be able to sit underneath him and and
learn the dark arts of coaching the
scrum and the line out yeah really
really lucky um to
for him to give up his time to help set
me up as well so yeah still he's another
one that's been a massive part of
setting this union
exciting times but um let's get to the
players any players who you think are
going to have a massive season who are
you excited to see out there um this
year i'm excited to see them all you
know we had a good group i think about
28 players playing super rugby so
some of those guys it was their first
year at super rugby the guys at moana
and the drawer and a few guys floating
around the other kiwi super teams and
really excited to see how they come back
into the fold after the first six months
being involved in super rugby and from
what i've heard and what i've seen so
far it's it's good things so uh
guys off the top of my head willie
havilly uh levi amu has been outstanding
uh lucha there he is
gotta get a front row in there
uh he'll appreciate the shout out uh max
hicks another one yeah um guys it been
their first full year of super rugby and
uh to see what they come back in the
nick they come back in and how excited
they are um just flows through the group
so can't wait to see them get out on the
track and it's fair to say you do have a
pretty special bond with um that man
luca inch father son a lot of guys call
you
how's that relationship formed oh it's
been good mate i think ever since he was
at nelson college in the first 15 we
started working together and just
trying to help each other out really i
was a new coach he was a player trying
to make it and
again just trying to get better with the
the scrummaging and
he was a exciting young prospect at
school and um just took a little bit of
nurturing and
you know just the work that we've done
and uh the relationship we've formed
over the few years is probably pretty
evident throughout the team now that we
get along alright a fair bit of banter
but uh he's a good kid so he's got a big
future right he's a special kid
but yeah that's probably um
probably it for the season obviously
it's going to be a massive year ahead
for tasman and i'm looking forward to
working with you personally so
but i do want to know a little bit more
about you get to your journey um you're
not just the rugby coach like i said in
the intro you were a player first and a
butcher so plenty to chat about but
let's start at the start for you um what
was your upbringing like where did you
grow up yes i was born and bred on the
east side of town in christchurch in new
brighton and bexley um unfortunately all
the family home and everything was
demoed in the after the earthquakes but
uh yeah grew up over that side of town
and really enjoyed it i spent a bit of
time on the west coast as well
and a weak town called o'hara and that
helped shaped
uh my teenage years the early part of my
teenage years and that was a great place
to grow up just the freedom of the
outdoors and when did you move over
there uh would have been the start of
high school so yeah yeah just went
straight over there into green mouth
high school and yeah uh chipped away
over there i met a
good core group of friends that have
still got mates over there now and um
yeah really enjoyed my time growing up
there with my two younger brothers so on
the dairy farm and running the mark oh
yeah [ __ ] you would have been were you
playing code over there yeah playing a
bit of footy mate so it was uh
you played rugby and league so we had
rugby on a sad day in league on a sunday
uh rugby for blake town and league for
waureka hornets on the sunday so uh she
was a big old weekend we were pretty
poked on monday getting on the bus to go
to school but uh yeah i loved it loved
that part of uh growing up and
yeah some real fond memories on the
coast did you go good at code either one
uh you enjoyed yeah enjoyed playing both
yeah it was uh
pretty much all my rugby mates played
league on the sunday and
uh the defensive side of league really
enjoyed and probably that helped me in
my rugby career a bit later on but uh
yeah really enjoyed it at the time over
there and um it kind of helped set me up
to come back and finish my high school
career uh finished my high school time
career i only had two years back in
christchurch uh so came back over to
christchurch to finish high school at uh
which was real special so why they moved
back to christchurch uh footy was
starting to go pretty good and something
i sort of you know
started to focus on could be a
opportunity once i left school
to
chase a dream i guess and
yeah like i said it was going pretty
good on the coast and
my dad had stayed in christchurch so
there was an opportunity to come back
and live with him and
it was around finding which school to go
to and there were a couple of offers to
go to private boys schools but um
stayed in the public and
my whole family had gone through arunui
so
at the time they'd
set up a sports academy and a rugby
academy was just about to start as well
so i came back over from the coast and
did my sixth and seventh form year 12
and year 13
and the rugby academy so there was yeah
pretty pretty unique at the time and
probably a little bit ahead of the time
actually we
uh
you do sort of half your day of
mainstream school and the other half of
the day would be um rugby specific
training down at uh qe2 so after school
every day a half half a half half a
school class right you might do the
first two morning periods and mainstream
school then your last three would be
doing rugby and then the tuesday would
be
first three school and last two rugby so
um yeah that was awesome awesome time
and again played rugby in league
through the
year 12 year 13. were they successful
obviously with that program it'd be hard
not to be uh the rugby side of things
yeah was new for us a lot of the boys
that played league mainly leading up to
that and we had a real uh real good
coach and john rangahuna who's put a lot
of time and effort and it's really
passionate about the rugby side of
things and
uh we've made a few finals and
semi-finals i think
uh one year
we had a first of things semi-final
against christ college on the sad day
that we lost and then uh played the
league final against saint paul's on the
sunday which we won so
um she was a big weekend and uh you had
to get over the rugby loss pretty quick
and the
the celebrations after the league when
were
uh there was no school on monday
were you uh always a hooker and rugby
yeah always a hooker in rugby union so
um no transformation from loose forward
to
uh never been blessed with those fast
twitch fighters jimmy so uh yes ever
since i started playing 40 i think is in
the front row and uh my dad's a front
row my brother's a front row so yeah
and then yeah played a bit of a hooker
and second row league as well so oh okay
sure just a little bit peggy riddell is
that where the nickname came from no no
i'm thought no uh piggy no real story to
this one but the old man was called
porky so i guess that's a bit of a
tradition that runs in the family and it
wasn't until i went back to aranui where
dad had been at school and uh he was
actually mates with the coach johnny i
mentioned before and he just started
yelling and screaming piggy on the
training field so it kind of stuck from
there how did the old man get the
nickname porky well i think he was a
little bit rotund in his
that is probably a better story than
that i don't think he was a big lad but
uh yeah just stuck with me from there
yeah and so then what was your pathway
from school what you sort of mentioned
that this your move was to give rugby a
go make it a profession so
um how had you try and um succeed in
that post footy i post school yeah post
school was
you know i wasn't the most gifted rugby
player so to speak i was a hard worker
and a bit of a grafter and
didn't make any academies or anything i
made sort of canterbury age grade teams
under 16 18's 19's
um i think coming out of school
i wasn't in the academy so um yeah
there's a bit of a
i guess a bit of debate with my parents
around what what life looked like after
school yeah um
i wanted to have a year off but
the old man wasn't having that under his
roof so
i wanted to have a year off and go to
university the following year and he
sort of come back at me with well if you
go to university you're probably not
going to be able to play rugby because
you're going to have to work and if
you're working you can't train so you
need to pay for university
okay
and then about two weeks after that
conversation it might have been in term
four
um my stepmother comes home with a with
a job advert for a butcher's
apprenticeship so
that's a whole nother yarn but uh
yeah that's kind of how how that sort of
went and i just went into a club
christchurch rugby club and
um yeah paved my way through there got
into the academy eventually and
uh yeah long story short a couple of
years in the canterbury academy
graduated through that and made the
shift to tessie so true let's go back to
the butchery um how did you so were you
keen to be a butcher or you sort of get
pushed into that no i just wanted to
have a year off and
enjoy no school and uh
yeah just live life i guess and go to
uni the year after but
dad painted a pretty blank pizza little
picture i wouldn't be able to play rugby
if i went to university so
um yeah the job advert cut out of the
newspaper and they sort of put it by my
school lunch box
okay that's a hint and uh
the old man actually knew the guy who
run the butcher's shop at the at walsh's
wholesale meets chris welsh was his name
and
i finished school and started my
butcher's apprenticeship two weeks after
school finished so uh yeah it was
awesome yeah to start my apprenticeship
wasn't something i'd ever thought about
um but yeah thoroughly enjoyed my
apprenticeship was hard yacker it was
any apprenticeship is but uh
yeah really enjoyed it and kind of
i guess went the long way around trying
to get into the academy and
probably set me up well for uh how the
rest of my rugby and business future
panned out so you must add some sort of
interest into butchering and cutting up
animals or something or does it just
burn nothing just no interest whatsoever
wasn't a hunter
yeah
a little bit of hunting on the coast
maybe shooting up possum or rabbit or
things like that but
no there's nothing it kind of just
i had nothing else planned really after
school apart from wanting to go to
university and i had my university
entrance i just didn't want to go
straight away so
um yeah the fact that you know once i
went and had my initial meeting with the
uh at walsh's that um yeah sort of was
able to plan my future a little bit and
but what a year in when i made the
academy and then it all sort of started
to piece piece together so when you are
a butcher apprentice what's your what's
your sort of role what's it look like
yes
killing the animals yes what are you
just slicing them up or no you're the
bottom of the bottom
you get all that you get all the good
jobs so um yeah dicing
meats sitting on the same cutter meat
for hours on end and
um eventually you work your way up and i
guess it's it's the dream to be the the
guy who's killing them is that oh no you
know you want to be bone in the mouth
you know if you show you've got to do
your time it's like any apprenticeship
you've got to learn your trade and you
start at the bottom and work your way up
so you start off making mints and dicing
beef and chicken and pork and
all the uh all the jobs that the
butchers don't don't want and
yeah it was hard work it was you know
you kind of had to bite your tongue at
times and yeah uh 5 a.m in the morning
until sort of three or four in the
afternoon you should do a full noise but
uh really rewarding as well at the end
of it you worked hard um you got paid
well for it at the time and
you got an apprenticeship at the end of
it so
how good is that and then you spoke
about your rugby and it was the move up
to nelson bays where it really that was
the opportunity you were speaking about
a where sort of really started to kick
off for you
yeah so yeah
at the time i was doing my
apprenticeship or a year into that i'd
played colts grade 40 at christchurch
and matt sexton was the academy manager
and sort of gave me the call and they
were keen to have a look at me and
um worked out really well with my
apprenticeship um as i moved further up
the ranks and got my butcher's
certificate i was able to become a beef
boner and yet sort of go hard and go
home sort of get the work done and
you're out of there so some days i've
finished about 1 32 o'clock and then
just go straight to the academy gym and
train for the afternoon and uh
yes i sort of two or three years of
doing that got my apprenticeship got
through the academy and
there were quite a backlog of hookers in
christchurch at the time and some really
good really good players and couldn't
really see a pathway there and
i got a phone call from dr wayne love
who was a
love doctor
the nelson bay's coach at the time and
um there was an opportunity to play
division two for nelson bays and
knowing that tasman was forming the
following year in 2006 i thought you
know here's my opportunity and didn't
know anyone in nelson i'd only been
there on holidays as a young fella and i
sort of packed my bags and uh moved to
the turf hotel for
for six months as a 20 year old so it
was good times is it the greatest place
on earth it was the greatest place on
earth at the time
so was your um tasman contract was that
part of the deal to move up or were you
sort of just backing yourself to be good
enough and impressed to make it the
following year yeah i just had to go
there and pack myself it was a you know
there was an opportunity with nelson
bays and you could see a pathway to
tasman and i was hearing pretty good
things about what was going to happen in
tasman and uh
yeah i just had to back myself and go up
there and commit to it and um yeah i did
yeah how'd you find that first year
playing for nelson bays obviously div
too
probably went all right that year they
were always sort of top four um often in
the finals and in that era so what was
that yeah like yeah it was really good
uh made the final against hawke's bay
and to play along some club legions of
kahuna fell gavin briggs uh mark milne
were
yeah it was really it was eye-opening
for a young 20 year old coming into that
environment but i really enjoyed it and
um you set me up for the following year
what were the div too initiations and
cordy's like right they was being loose
i could imagine crazy being a hell of an
enforcer yeah the off field was as good
as the on field or as important as the
on-field performance so yeah we're
pretty good at winning that game
the third half i think they called it
[Laughter]
those stories
no yarns that i can think of off the top
of uh now the tazzy stories kind of
override those ones there so yeah so the
following year um you do make that
tasman marco squad was uh how did you
find that out
oh that was all there i think uh dennis
brown and bev and cambodia were the
coaches at the time and um yeah early in
the year i got offered a contract for
for that and um yes i guess it um kind
of
made the move worth it and uh committed
to it and
uh yeah it was really exciting times
though those those early years of tassie
and there's some fairly good yarns
um but uh yeah it was really exciting
there was a big buzz around nelson and
marlborough and
um
yeah we run a mark in the first couple
of years we probably
probably weren't the most professional
outfit uh going around but we had a lot
of fun and um i guess that
set the pathway up for where we are now
we probably didn't have the on-field
performances but um there were
definitely some stepping stones that we
had to encounter um in those early years
as any new union or any new business
would have to do to to set you up for
the long run and
i think we definitely
engaged with our community uh we got the
support of new zealand rugby and the new
zealand rugby community and and they
really backed us and once we got that
and um
uh
the good story's got a couple of good
players couple good local lads come
through and and and we're away so
so when you speak about being in the div
ii to that following yeah what was the
biggest difference or was that sort of
what let them down there wasn't a big
difference between them
um yeah i think well we had a few new
guys come into the region and they
brought a level of professionalism
to the team where
fiki t paulo uh ben golling's tim taylor
from from over in europe and
um you know they kind of set us up
i guess it was the
you know it was new or something
exciting and and we played on that as as
players off the field as much as we did
on it and yeah um
yeah i guess it was always going to be
tough for us in those early years to
compete um with the
the bigger unions
but we knew eventually we could get
there and uh
took us took our time and
maybe we could have done things a little
differently in those early years but we
learned our lessons and that set us up
for where the club is at today so so how
did it how did it turn around obviously
one of the most successful
provincial unions in new zealand at the
moment what how did it all turn around
from the early struggles it took a
couple of good people to come into it
and and really start focusing a bit more
on the rugby side of things and and come
up with a brand and a
dna as to how the marco wanted to play
and uh two guys that were influential
that come to my mind were kieran kane
and leon macdonald and uh they sort of
came in and their rugby nows was second
to none leon was kieran kane was just a
absolute scientist of the game and had
some pretty out there ideas but wasn't
afraid to to try them and challenge the
norm and
i think that was really good because it
was a point of difference for us that
you know we were doing some things that
were probably a little bit of a hit
about time and other unions weren't
doing and and then having leon's rugby
iq come in there and his calmness and
he was really uh worked hard and got us
working hard and you know come from the
crusaders as well so he had a bit of
that background and uh set us up well
and on the field for you um
obviously you got a lot of game time and
you've got a couple of good seasons
there where you were the starting too um
one memory in particular that stands out
is your um
pig crawl post wellington um scored a
try pig crawl back to about the 22 or
something talk me through this one
we hadn't scored a few tries and we're
coming to the back end of the season and
uh
goodie andrew goodman was our captain at
the time and i think it was last game
and everyone had that a try so everyone
had to have a try scoring celebration
right you had the cheeseburger
i'd sort of jacked up without winger
cookie blair cook that you know if i was
to score a try he was a mad king pig
hunter
my nickname being pig if i scored a try
i'd crawl back to 22 and he'd run along
and stick me like a pig and i'd sort of
end up on the back
bloody looking like idiots
he never turned up and i'm sitting there
crawling back to the 22 and i'm the one
who looked like an idiot
and uh yeah the video comes out at least
once a month
we've always loved it eh you might be
able to get luca to do that i reckon
this year oh man i was pig crawling
through nightclubs all through my buddy
someone would yell out pink crawl and
i'd have to get down and crawl through
them
it was a bloody mess
oh that's right and any other um games
that sort of stand out for you the big
rand philly shield game i remember early
on against wellington as well any
memories from that
yeah there's yeah memories uh yeah i
guess as a union we haven't had too many
cracks at the ram philly shield and uh
yeah that was one that i was fortunate
enough to plan and
also unfortunately mr tackle that
led to a red card that probably cost us
the game so
well there's a few other things that
could spawn in that game against us but
uh yeah there was a good memory at the
cake tin and obviously those first away
wins i think beating waikato um up there
was a big one beating auckland at home
uh was another big
big sculpt the canterbury games were
always memorable ones um
so yeah there's some yeah real fond
memories of the time in the tassie doozy
the shield it wasn't your fault
he's still attacking him
yeah
no doubt but um so what why the move to
bar plenty obviously um tasman legend
yeah so i'd been with tazzy and uh been
with the crusaders for a couple of years
as well and i think started off at a
wider training group and
got a 14 or 15 games when uh flanny
broke his arm i sort of got the call up
into the into the squad and uh
got a full contract for one year down
there as a third hooker and then it's
kind of got the end of that time and
um young quentin macdonald was coming
through at tears he as well and he was
probably in line for the for that
crusader spot so
um he was going to overtake me at tez he
was nipping up my heels there for a year
or two and
a really good footy player
there was an opportunity it was back in
the day when you had to be in the
franchise to to be able to play for the
french horse and you had to play your
provincial footy there and uh battle
clinging after a hooker and white cat
the chiefs were after a hooker as well
so ended up signing a two-year contract
with the chiefs is uh up there and and
matching that with bayer plenty so uh
made the move up there with a another
tassie laid tristan moran and twisty hey
yeah what a lad favorite i think
get him on mate he's got some good yards
now that was good to move up there was
someone that i knew and
again it was a move where i'd never
really been to town or mount mongolia
and um just had to go out there and back
myself and give it a good match mate we
can't skip over your crusaders career
just like that
what was it like going into that
environment obviously um pretty
successful side obviously four pack with
lots of all black legends
you coming down from tasmania i don't
know how old you were what were you like
23-ish yeah i think i was yeah 24 25 i
think when i got my first crack down
there so
yeah i wasn't young i sort of matured a
little bit
a little bit
but that was it was yeah nerve-wracking
it was you like you said they were
pretty successful and had won a few
titles and
lucky enough that todd had been my uh
coach at tasman for a couple of years
and he was now the coach of the
crusaders so there was some familiar
familiarity around that and a few other
tassie boys down there so uh that was
good but it was pretty daunting you know
you
look up the guys like rich mccoy and uh
i played with a few of them
uh through age grade footy with crocky
and you know the frank's boys and carter
and that so knowing those guys kind of
helped him um but yeah it was definitely
a little bit daunting with the success
that they had and
just going there trying to be yourself i
think
you learned to heap but it was
awesome environment awesome culture
i guess
for me to to walk into and be a part of
and learn from so i took a lot out of it
mate what was the biggest difference
going from tassie which in the early
days you know was pretty loose to going
into that environment with you know
from the outside looking in it looked
like a pretty serious
um especially that four pack you got the
likes of breadth on i say richie mccall
these guys who um seem pretty straight
and narrow what was it what was it
actually like oh open my eyes to
professionalism that's for sure because
tazzy was new
we were professionals but we probably
weren't in some regards and uh to go
down there and just see how they
operate and set up themselves for the
week and to be able to perform on a sad
day was phenomenal like breadth on what
a machine made but um just yeah had
everything
eyes dotted t's crossed and um did
everything he needed to do to set
himself up to play play well on the set
then the ultimate professional and you
know guys like the franks's and
richie and that as well so being able to
see them and what they did uh for me um
being new to that environment uh kind of
helped me set me up for the rest of my
career as well so yeah really lucky loot
heaps and when you got a crack on the
field for the crusaders how are you
feeling
oh you just had to go there and back
yourself and trust what you know and it
was pretty simple the the messaging that
was given you just nailed your role and
as a hooker it was pretty easy so uh
throw your line out right hit lock at
yeah that was about it i got lucky
enough to
play a couple tours to south africa and
a couple of semi-finals against the
bulls at soweto and another one the next
year in the bulls at loftus-fursfeld so
those are memories that'll stick with me
for a long time and you're really lucky
to be able to to get those chances did
you win those no we lost both of them
they had lost both of them balls were
always powerhouse back then they
overwhelmingly stained one yeah
as well at altitude it was tough and
i think howard had worked out both years
we'd just done our tour didn't have to
come back for two weeks and go all the
way back for a semi-final so
there's a lot of sleeping pools
how did you find the hive out because um
you're extremely loud breather i'm not
sure if you've got breathing
troubles or not but
how'd you find breathing up an altitude
[Laughter]
it was one of those things it just
wasn't talked about you know it was
there but if we didn't talk about it
wasn't a thing so oh sure you know just
did it we didn't focus on it it wasn't
going to become an excuse for us so it
wasn't really spoken about much to be
fair until we got back so not till you
sort of think about it yeah uh
yeah we were fairly buggered by those
back into those semi-final games just
the nature of how our tour had been then
having to come home and go back again
was fairly tough so that's interesting i
always thought teams would sort of
prepare for
handling that or stuff but if you were
doing going there now would you talk
about it or would you make a plan around
it or you're aware of it but
i don't think it influences what you do
yeah too much you still go out there to
play footy and play and
uh the style of footy that you need to
play to win the game so um yeah i don't
think it becomes a part of your tactics
or uh we didn't at that time anyway yeah
so then you left the crusaders because
quinn mcdonald was coming through the
ranks is that right yeah that's what yep
and then you get the opportunity at the
chiefs uh move up to the bar plenty um
what was it like moving up there yeah
and you're living with twisty obviously
yeah living with twisty head it's uh had
its moments uh we had a lot of fun but
again got to play with some awesome
players up up at the bay and at the
chiefs as well um
liam mess and steven donald
uh at the chiefs and they have plenty
there colin burke tunnel latimer mike
delaney so yeah real good group of lads
in both teams again and uh really
enjoyed my time up there and loved the
difference in the cup differences in the
culture um and bail plenty was similar
to the tessie you know we've
uh a lot of good players
probably could have been a little bit
more fresh professional on the field
with how we set ourselves up uh to play
as athletes but uh yeah it's a good
times and was it just you and twisty
living together uh myself and twisty and
uh sam kane actually had come down a
young sam kane had
been put up with us
hell of an introduction for
the future all black captain to be
living with you two crook roosters young
country lad from referral coming in with
a couple of front rowers from nelson and
marlborough so
uh though we had a good time in that
flat uh
yeah it would have been a bit of an eye
opener for him but
what was twisty like to live with
i was good mate is uh awesome character
and a lot of fun
uh pretty intense as well real deep
thinker of the game and life but uh yeah
we had a lot of fun together and yeah
the moments that you know i look back on
and they were good good memories and
were you moving back and forth from
hamilton to bayer planning did you do
that a couple of times yeah did that a
couple of times and um
my wife and partner at the time nikki
she was back in nelson as well she was a
school teacher so there was a bit of
commuting there oh yeah it wasn't a
cheap flight out of town at a nelson
that's right so
um yeah there's a fair bit going on and
the chiefs didn't get didn't see a lot
of game time there's heck alley at naila
de melmatch there at the time so um yeah
they were the two gun hookers up there
but uh you enjoyed my time up there two
years long distance
two years long distance nicki was coming
up a lot as well so uh yeah it's just
what you had to do in those times yeah
yeah she had a pretty good job at the
local high school so so who were you
living with in hamilton oh ben may oh
you're kidding
all the lads
that was good but oh we had some ideas
in that place that
now we had the dog swag and uh he pretty
much got it he got the run of the hit
the flat uh phil burley in there as well
oh true uh so there's a good group of us
but bam and i sort of stuck tight as uh
another nelson led and um well we yeah
yeah crazy but
all the waterload listeners will know a
fair bit about ben may already from his
episode but
what was it like living with him was he
was he like that all the time yeah no
he's a good lad yeah absolutely
we just worked hard played hard and had
a lot of fun together and if we're
wearing out on some mischievous duck
hunting bloody duck shooting competition
or
boosting back over to mount maunganui to
get sushi on our days off or
we're
we even tried to live on a budget for
some point just eating spaghetti
bolognese five days a week what was that
all about oh man i don't know what we
were trying to do we didn't achieve it
mate he's got a metabolism like a bloody
racehorse so he could get away with it
and i just kept blowing out
i don't know if he's stitching me out
for what was that something you always
struggled with
through your career was keeping your
weight down or your skin folds down how
could you tell jim oh i couldn't i
couldn't mate
no it was funny you say that how did you
know
uh it was a bit of a battle yeah or was
it naturally gifted uh with a fast
metabolism but uh
yeah the 500 cows at 5 a.m at the chiefs
with oh sure phil healey and molly rifle
wasn't was it nicer was that for being
having skin folds too high to the air
too high their skin folds and the
spaghetti diet got ya
carbs are no good
uh
yeah 500 calories at 5am and i think
even one year i came back and got an
award for being the biggest loser so oh
sherry what lost the most weight oh it's
going to skim fold so yeah claim to fame
but you mentioned um hecarim and alan de
melmotch were ahead of you as hooker so
did you get much of an opportunity on
the field at the chiefs
no no bug rule mate so
yeah they were pretty highly i think
both all blacks at the time as well so i
was just chipping away in the background
and doing what i needed to do to set the
team up and uh it was interesting
experience of the chiefs after being
with the crusaders um
and being in that environment the
culture and would have driven that
to going up there and uh ian foster was
our coach at the time and scott macleod
so the current all black coaches and
they were kind of in their early days as
well as coaches really good really
intelligent
um rugby brains and
we just didn't quite have that mix of
the culture side of things right up
there at the time and it wasn't till uh
renny came in the year after and i'd
finished by then retired uh where they
brought in the chief's mana and that
kind of flicked the switch for them
because they had all the tell me and had
some talent up there
but as soon as they got that off-field
stuff right and the chief's mana came
and they were away so uh yeah it was
yeah interesting
really eye-opening after being down yeah
christchurch to garner hamilton and
seeing what they were running up there
now how frustrating is it being in that
923
for you know pretty much a couple of
years how frustrated did you get
oh you push hard mate but i don't think
you get frustrated
um you do what you can do and you push
your case as hard as you can but
essentially the team's bigger than you
and you do your best to set those guys
up and
you know after a while i knew my place
in the team and
that was my role so um you had to
provide good banter and train harder
right and you nailed it love that and
you mentioned your retirement so um how
did that come about uh just through
shoulder surgery um yeah i needed to get
that tidied up i was coming off contract
with the bay and
um as i said before nicki was at home
back in nelson and um back then he sort
of said i'll get your shoulder sort of
come back up through club rugby and
uh we'll look at sony there i think i
was about 32 at the time so um yeah it
was time to look at life after rugby and
um
yeah that's sort of how it came about so
um i thought i probably could have had
another year or two in me but i had i
was pretty content with what i'd done in
my professional career and i chased the
dream that i was after and knew that i
had to get into something else so and
what was that did you have a plan post
it or like to walk away from rugby when
you've still got
um some left is pretty hard unless you
sort of have something in place did you
have something in place no nothing
really in place we had a house and stuff
back in nelson so i had to come back and
find something and
always going off to do something for
myself was was sort of the plan what
that was wasn't too sure but i had a
career um business
for a while i wouldn't
probably should have been kicked out of
the front row club because i was under
100 kilos
first time since i was about 12 i reckon
my parent my dad stopped talking to me
there was yeah there was a lot of
competition for the tickets and that
that time and online shopping hadn't
really kicked off yet so it was hard
yakka and um
i enjoyed it but uh it probably just
wasn't the lifestyle that i was looking
for at the time after too much exercise
too much exercise that might have helped
me with my rugby actually i should have
tried it earlier
so yeah i managed to sell that and
worked in a bit of civil construction
for a little bit for the local sponsor
of the um
club that i was helping play a coach for
and
that was going pretty good i had a
pretty good role out there i've been
able to come you know start coaching and
they were backing me and helping in that
civil construction
uh area was good
uh did that for about two two years
enjoyed my time there but uh we still
wanted to do something for ourselves and
work for ourselves and
i remember just jumping and jumping more
allowed to jump into the mad butcher
stuff in there
i'd kind of met sir peter at a
sponsors sort of function we're setting
up the opening of the claudelands arena
at walking and jokingly after the end of
the sausages or whatever just said that
you know i'll open up a mad butcher when
i finished playing footy and
there'd been no butcher and nelson for a
nice standalone more decent butcher
there was only sort of one and out in
richmond and
we kind of just started thinking you
know is that something we could get into
and
uh got the backing of our family and uh
fired off an email to the head office in
auckland and they came back straight
away asking if we could get to auckland
next week so sure yes you move things
things progress pretty quickly with that
and what'd you do up in auckland like
what do you have to do yeah just well
you had to be a butcher to buy into the
franchise
so zach
hey
yeah thanks mum and dad for that one uh
so you showed up there had a three or
four hour meeting up at the head office
up there with michael morton and dan
adams sir peter was out of the business
by that stage but uh his son-in-law is
now running it he's a top rooster so
uh had a meeting with them um drive
around auckland around a couple of the
mad butchers
got back to head office they said
find a site nelson and it's yours so
from that meeting to opening
um took us about 12 13 months to um find
a site get it prepared it was yeah we
ended up buying the old stoke rugby club
and set that up as a butcher shop so
right and how hard was that to set up
like obviously you hadn't had much
experience in running your own business
or things like that so
how'd you manage yeah i guess that that
being a part of a franchise was uh not
having that business experience but i
could be a butcher being a part of the
franchise was you know a real good
selling point for us rather than just
going off by ourselves
they had all the knowledge and know how
they sort of had processes in place to
set up the shop but it was still a
massive learning curve going into
business and and like michael morton was
he was a massive help to us and still is
a massive help um to how we run the shop
now and
i think we ended up i think we opened in
2014. uh so we've had it eight years now
um we've just had a uh
our first
uh baby was born sort of three months
before the store opening so
it was mad it was it was crazy time at
the second biggest opening in franchise
history and we were just yeah six well
probably 70 80 hour weeks there for the
first sort of you
two two and a half years it was two and
a half years i was 70 yeah it was great
with a newborn
massive learning curve and you have the
highs of your opening
um you know the first couple of months
and then the bills start rolling and
yeah like holy heck of this you know
we're going to pay these on the 20th the
next month and
sort of you have your heiser opening and
we pumped up the opening so we knew it
was going to be big but you know you
sort of come down and find your place in
the market and that took a wee while for
us to find that so it was a little bit
nervous times there for
about six or seven months in sure you
know things start going backwards after
you you know your early excitement um
and then you find your place in your
market and start building again from
there but yeah it was really nervous but
really lucky to have that support we had
from our head office how did you build
the um opening up so well like obviously
it was a pretty big opening what'd you
do oh we had the ute sign written and we
had billboards around town and uh i
think we're one of the first franchises
to have social media as well so yeah
pumping it up through there
2 a.m the morning of the opening i was
driving around the countryside putting
in little picket signs of
mad butcher opening today and lychee he
rang me at about hub us two to make sure
i was out there doing it g'day boy how
are you getting on
i'll see you at 7am
so he came down he was flying in for the
opening causing a bloody ruckus that he
does
uh
yeah it was full of full-on man like
those those were crazy days like i
thought rugby was tough and training and
and the day in day out of that but
nothing compared to
owning your own business
and having staff and
customers and bills and stuff you had to
pay so yeah it was massive were there
times where you thought um [ __ ] what
have i done here i sort of want to get
out of this or
uh
yeah there was a few squeaky squeaky
times there and
we just had to dig down and work harder
and the supermarkets came at us real
hard like uh that was one of the tough
things is the competition and trying to
control what we could control but
you know every week i'd go out there on
a monday morning put my new signs out an
hour later the supermarket across the
road would come out undercutting me and
really
so trying to
i guess find our place in the market but
then find a point of difference for us
that sets us apart from the supermarket
was also huge so we spent a lot of time
on our quality and customer service and
having a real point of difference around
our social media and
uh bits and pieces like that so you had
to work hard for it like uh they were
coming hard and
and we just i knew that
i knew we could stay in it we could
survive but i just had to really knuckle
down and um wasn't much time i was
leaving five am in the morning getting
home at
seven eight o'clock at night and uh you
know as we sit at the newborn and uh
yeah she was tough mate must have been
tough on necky as well yeah tough on
nikki because she was running the
business from home as well as well as
having
a newborn too so um you know we learned
a lot but we we stayed tight and dug in
and and we're at the other side of it
now eight years later and uh it's been a
tough journey but a really rewarding one
too and while you're both under the pump
um you decide to have another baby yet
another baby that uh yes we had our
second as well and uh yeah that was a
really scary uh time in life for us
because nikki as you know
um got a
a virus a one and a million virus
called milo fisher syndrome while she
was pregnant with our
second daughter ruby so
it's a virus that attacks the
um nerves and it started in her eyes so
i come home from work one day and uh
she had blurry vision
um and she you know had um wore glasses
and contacts and bits and pieces so we
just thought you know give it a couple
of days and started progressively
getting worse and went to the doctor and
to the eye specialist and next thing
we're being told we've got to go in to
see the um
get cat scans because they're thinking
it could be tumors and all sorts of
stuff and
uh that was really scary time and and we
were
yeah the shop sort of played second
fiddle to making sure that her health
was right and
really good family support nelson with
her family around us but um
it was yep just by chance an absolute
miracle that uh there was a specialist
in there at the time
who it's
i think she'd had a patient like this a
couple of years ago over in
uh china or asia somewhere all right and
it's a one in a million type thing yeah
one and a minute it's not very common
and she just said i think it's this you
need a full tran blood transfusion now
so
while being five or six months pregnant
she went for a full blood transfusion
and if she hadn't had that she would
could have been in a whole whole world
of trouble so
yeah it was real yeah real scary times
but
got through the other side of it so she
didn't know that this was going to work
at the time this was just a bit of a
stab in the dark just trusting us yep
bit of a stab in the dark and trusting
this uh specialist
that she knew what she was talking about
and even then it was still not
guaranteed that nicki's vision would
come back or it would stop the virus
eating the nerves and i think once the
virus got down to your throat it started
affecting your breathing you were going
to have to be put on a ventilator and
all sorts of things was going to look
pretty tough from there so we managed to
get it quick enough but that the vision
still wasn't guaranteed it could come
back in six days six weeks six months
six years but i think it took a couple
of months and her vision came right the
nerves naturally repaired themselves and
um yes came right she's pretty good now
but yeah no more babies
mate so her eyes is it always the eyes
for this um virus not 100 sure yeah i'm
not not sure where it can start but i
think her case has now been put in the
medical journals now
it's a point of reference for
yeah if it comes up again i've got a
study there to a case study to go back
and have a look on so and how blind was
like how bad was her eyes eyesight yeah
she had to hold her hand to walk oh
really
couldn't see anything so everything was
just completely blurred so true so how
long was that period when she couldn't
see at all when you had to be a guide
dog by the time guy picked quite big by
the time she had rubio vision was
starting to come right but she had to
have ruby under cesarean and bits and
pieces but she'd come right by then as
well so um yeah all right that's crazy
and then no no after effects so like now
she's sweet no after a fix just
yeah a baby you can't have a baby so
yeah they uh did that and uh yeah the
business was still tracking along and
yeah um yeah life still had to be it had
to go on so
get back into it crazy that is a yarn so
you weren't you're obviously pretty busy
with um butchering kids so you decide to
get into coaching yeah it's mad
yeah i guess
yeah tough i was always a bit of a
natural progression of my old man was a
coach and
pretty decent at it and
worked for new zealand rugby as a coach
educator as well so um
yeah it was
something that kind of
naturally just happened and
uh
he's really good hookers out there
coaching there and um
front rows make good coaches
[Laughter]
and they're all bull too all front row
coaches are bull yourself chase ryan
chrono a few ball coaches yeah there is
a good [ __ ] could be something in there
right what do you reckon it's a secret
part of it
would you ever hire a
full-headed hair
front row coach oh i don't know that
yeah you start to ask questions
but your pathway you started with club
40.
yeah sort of did
you know a lot of ex-players come out
the coaching footing there and then
that's good i think there's a place for
that but i sort of knew i had to do it
take the long game with it and at that
point in time with the business i was
still fully immersed into that there
wasn't really time to
coach a hell of a lot so the club side
of things
um was a good fit for me at the time and
uh that started garner wright and
chris goodman asked me to help out with
a couple of tasman under 19 teams and
then all of a sudden i was involved in
crusader
juniors and development teams and tasman
b and
uh kind of just yeah it was it was good
because i wanted to learn my trade and
coaching and start on the on the ground
you know at grassroots yeah work my way
up and yeah i think it served me well so
was it a hard hard to commit to that
because there's obviously at that level
there's pretty
little slash no financial benefit from
doing it a so was this all part of the
big picture long-term plan
yeah i guess yeah you're giving back to
the game really that was my sort of
philosophy around it and i knew if i
worked hard and
at my craft of coaching then potentially
there could be it could be
an opportunity moving forward and it's
not really until
last year that up until then i've sort
of been volunteering my time and that's
kind of what you've got to do it's no
different to your butcher's
apprenticeship i guess
do your time until you're ready to to
make a step into that professional game
and uh you know i was lucky enough to
get that opportunity so now you must
have good support from nikki to
i guess
allow you to i mean you're pretty you're
pretty busy as it was being a dad a
butcher running your own business um to
volunteer and give up so much time into
coaching which is obviously time
consuming as well huge commitment from
your wife yeah no she's um yeah she's
backed me 100 and really grateful for
um the time that she allows me to go out
and coach because it is a massive um
commitment and making sure i have that
balance she makes sure i have that
balance uh sorry
um but you know i'm really grateful to
have her and her family and my family
back in christchurch my two daughters
that um
yeah that are right behind me and um
you're really grateful for their support
and the time that they allow me away
from them um and you know just
yeah it's tough it's a tough gig
especially those early years but um
yeah it's paying paying off now i think
is it what now he's co-head coach tasman
marco and what's the dream what's uh
what's the goals for your coaching well
it was always a dream to coach where i
played jimmy and tasman gave me my first
opportunity so to be able to be in the
hot seat now with corny is
really exciting something i'm really
proud of and uh really looking forward
to
my journey as a co-head coach as well as
still looking after set piece but
i think you know you would be kidding
ourselves if we want we weren't
aspirational and wanted to have a crack
at super rugby and beyond and um
obviously first and foremost
looking after tazzy and making sure that
we're successful here and and the club's
successful for for a long period of time
is
my main priority but uh yeah super rugby
if something was to come knocking then
you'd be silly not to look at it well
i've noticed
being on the podcast guests i've had on
rugby players and generally their career
gets a pretty big spike after coming on
the podcast they talk about their goals
or what they want to achieve it might be
a japan contract and it does seem to
happen so
um if you're putting it out there that
you want to be a super rugby coach
i'll be putting my money on that yeah
uh next year for sure but this will be a
good way to test the theory out to see
if you are i'm a super rugby coach in
2023 let me know if you get any messages
yeah well if you do want uh dan perrin
to coach you um head over to the
waterlet instagram page
and just message me and i'll pass you in
to the right man but speaking of the
instagram page we did get plenty of
messages uh questions and stories for
the mad butcher so i will go through
some of these um first one what's your
favorite twisty moran story
obviously a big favorite for a few
wodely listeners
oh
there's a lot of stories of twisty moran
but
uh
one you can't beat waking up on a
weekday morning to twisty in the kitchen
nude uh cooking your poached eggs on
toast and breakfast mate
can't beat that can't beat it and it was
fairly common as well where you had to
get his dose of vitamin d
um but uh yeah that's a it's something
that's burnt in my retina uh
forever
vitamin d on the d
that's probably not wrong
and this was living with sam kane what
did a young 18 year old sam kane think
of twisty cooking and poached eggs and
food for breakfast yeah sammy cain was a
sleeper anyway he'd love to lay in so i
don't know if he got there the
opportunity he knew it was probably
going on and sleeping on and on purpose
but i knew i was getting
my breakfast cooked for me so uh that
was it was good fun yeah
living with sam kane on sam kane what
was it noticeable that he was going to
have the career he has
from that early stage there
oh here he was he was a great human
awesome character and i guess the thing
i was lucky enough to play with richie
and and sammy coming in like the the
character and the way they conducted
themselves and how they spoke was
like it was crazy how identical and
similar it was and you kind of knew he
was going to be something special and
i think the first time on the footy
field were involved in a team's
tournament for for our club tarana
sports
and he was just absolutely cutting guys
in half and i'm like holy heck this
kid's backing it up yeah and there's a
little bit of a dust up and he fronts up
and goes toe-to-toe with a couple of
these big island boys from counties and
sure
yeah this kid's this kid's not bad and
uh
yeah just his character and his work
ethic and um his mannerisms you knew he
was going to be something special so it
was awesome you're really lucky to play
alongside him as a 18 19 year old as
yeah
just it's he was
unreal right that is that is cool to
hear okay next question what's the best
cut of meat for a summer barbie this one
came in a few times people want to get
the butcher's inside yeah i love scotch
fillet mate with a bit of marbling
through it so uh hot hard and fast on a
barbecue bit of salt and pepper 200 to
250 grams about the right portion size
for me so
uh that's my go-to over summer mate oh
mate the detail in there
if you went 300 grams what happens is
that
anything change is that just too much oh
dear poor poor everything important mate
portion controls 250's the perfect
amount yeah for me yeah you might like a
300 grammer though
oh yeah so it's just individual
preferences it's not going to help you
yeah ask your local butcher to cut the
sides for your mate they'll do anything
oh mate how good is that get to the
butcher and um stop these bullies um the
supermarket bullies so what about this
slice
the cup uh what are they price slice
yeah
cutting yeah undercutting undercutting
that's it
that's nuclear okay next one how much of
chicken wings this week
5.99 a kilo far right that's cheap
real plain and marinated
so free marinade yeah we'll add the
marinade to the kilo price so
five
your marinades included in the kilo
price that wouldn't be much not a hell
of a lot of chinese honey marinade on
your chicken wings get them on the
barbecue for the all blacks tonight oh
mate
have you got any discounts for waterload
listeners 20 percent mate you can't
jealous you know jimmy have a bit of
merch on even better scents
20 if you say what a lad at the counter
you listen to this podcast you say what
led at the counter will go 20
and this is uh mad butcher's nationwide
or oh
no
i'll get my bloody hands chopped just
the one at stake just the one in nelson
oh mate love that so if you are
listening in the nelson region or
probably in the south island it's worth
worth the trip up that's 20 that's good
stuff okay next one can you give us your
best peter leech impression you gave us
a little teaser there
uh looked like a good one g'day it's
real mate the mad butcher this week get
your local mad butcher chicken breast
7.99 a kilo that's right
7.99 a kilo get up the vodafone warriors
wow
mate i've had some impressions on this
podcast before but that is definitely
the top that beats celicia rassi's
lebron james i think that was that was
impressive to see live
in the flesh have you practiced that or
have you learned that oh yeah a lot of a
lot of practice
you would have seen uh the mad dan's
videos on a saturday morning at the mad
butcher so i'd try to take the piss a
little bit there and uh just be a bit of
time in there practicing for that one so
what's the story behind those videos
like um they do they are pretty popular
i know with the boys and um around the
nelson
yeah it was just a point of difference
of marketing and uh it was something
after it might have been a bit hungover
one saturday morning and we'll give it a
crack and had some good specials to
to show off and uh again you know it's
just another point of difference for us
to that supermarkets weren't doing and
um
yeah kind of got a little bit carried
away with it and uh but provide a good
banter with the customers coming in the
store and me being in the store and
uh big willy behind the camera he gets
his fair share of uh people wanting to
know who he is
so he was pushing it more so than what i
was
and yeah sort of just it actually had a
real good effect on the day's sales as
well so the customer count went up the
sales went up and you know once you've
seen the dollars coming in
to give this another crack and um yeah
it's kind of just that's crazy so you
actually could see a massive uh
noticeable difference when you'd
released one of those videos yeah yeah
100
so yeah it made it made a big difference
and just provided a bit of banter yeah
again with something different so sure
why don't you do one every day or that
sort of overkill yes a little bit of
that overkill once you've seen it
trying to find content jimmy you know
fair enough yeah okay next one um
what is your best end of year do this
will be good oh the fountain of youth
for tassie 2008
at the walker yeah i know every bit of
detail of this one yeah that was one of
the greats yeah so explain what is the
fountain of youth this was my first year
in tasman actually i had no idea when
they said what it was going to be but
learned pretty quickly uh so the old
waka um had a at a bar that you could
sort of walk around and you just leave
the keg tap on and it's not allowed to
be turned off until the the key exempted
so there's the whole team just
walking and uh like clockwork around the
bar and you're not allowed to you've got
to finish your vessel by the time you
get back round to the tap again and the
tap's not allowed to be turned off so
that was a day two event um so there
were some pretty messy
uh punters there and um yeah that was it
was a big old day yeah i remember the
first couple of thinking oh this isn't
too bad and you know well geez just kept
going i started getting pretty tough
yeah a few unnamed players were taking a
few shortcuts trying to
get rid of their points before they got
back to the table in suspicious ways but
uh you know she was she was good fun
mate there's some good times especially
in those early days like you said okay
next one
what's your current skin folds this is
um your ex trainer wayne taylor checking
in tails tails thanks a lot mate you
changed my life uh
you wouldn't trust the skinny butcher
jimmy so i couldn't tell you
[Laughter]
but more than when you're doing your
courier run
more than the run uh more than when i
was playing footy but uh a good question
tails though
he was a good man he was had a massive
influence on me and my early days at
tessie and changing my my body and
changing my mindset to be a professional
athlete so
but yeah it's not something i'm
particularly too worried about these
days fair enough
you're a butcher
like you say skinny butcher on a scale
of one to ten how calm are you in the
coaches box
well it's been a bit of a work on to be
fair jimmy uh
i'm no craig bellamy uh but
i think it's important that you you show
your passion and
and you're shouting the right way and um
i guess it's uh more so
i guess when we're sending down messages
and the communication
is probably as long as that's calm and
and you're collected and it's simple
messaging that's fine but yeah i'm
pretty passionate in the coaches box and
get pretty excited and i've had a few
the old apple
watch heart rate warnings
during a few games uh the semi-final
last year levy moore against hawke's bay
turnover was
that
sent me through the red lining
but i think if yeah if you're not
emotionally involved and passionate
about it then
yeah there's something wrong how often
would you um watch send off the alarm
well i think i had two last years
just tense moments is it dead it's time
it's but no it's good stuff i love it so
that's what we're in it for love there
okay next one oh this question's from
our major swans sponsor swoosh
mate you should actually get on swoosh
like with peter leitch you too would be
um unreal on there but
um if you could get a video shout out
from any celebrity who would it be and
why
i've got a couple actually uh
my first one at the moment current uh he
would have to be a rugby coach eddie
jones oh yeah he's an interesting
rooster i'd love to
uh have a wee message from him and we
pepe pep talk from him so yeah he
coached his channel he's everything he's
probably organized there that'd be good
but uh and uh yeah real left field this
one um my daughters are actually right
into a dell
at the moment so they walk around the
house belting out easy on me and all
sorts of tunes and i've actually quite
been quite enjoying sitting there on a
after work and watching adele on tv so
geez there he is get here on the screen
singing happy birthday
can we make that happen oh i don't know
about adele but father of the year i
wouldn't have chosen that i wouldn't
have picked you is it a big adele
um fan but there you go oh she's lost a
lot of weight too she might have started
a courier run
she don't need to start noku
[Laughter]
no but what a voice she has
can you do an adele impression
i don't think so my daughter's in here
okay next time okay
last question best piece of advice you
have for a waterlab listener
uh
uh
be yourself and beck yourself
uh and be humble
you know uh
if you're not out there like you gotta
be yourself don't try to be someone that
you're not yeah um you gotta back
yourself it's a tough world these days a
lot of critics
um social media and stuff can you know
you can read a lot into that but i think
if you back yourself and
and you've got the talent and the skill
set to have a crack then and by means do
it but remember where you've come from
and who's in your corner
um by being humble as well so
it's a bit of advice that's been passed
on to me especially through my coaching
journey so jesus i've made
i say this a lot but that was probably
the best advice we've had because you
didn't just know one thing i think you
covered all three things and nailed it
to perfection so
you're obviously a world lead listener
because that was prepared
planned advice and mate i love that one
because so true so many haters out there
back yourself
be humble
and what's the first one be yourself be
yourself yeah crucial love it love it
love it but
mate piggy what a journey what a story
um really appreciate you coming on the
podcast
like you said throughout this like
nothing's really happened quickly before
you've worked hard for everything that's
come to you so your rugby career
slow build up but you got there in the
end same with you your hard work and the
butchery and now you're coaching you've
you've been grinding away for a few few
years now with not much reward to see
you succeed and get to where you want to
be at the moment's been
pretty inspiring for a young coach
coming through and mate really looking
forward to working with you this year
hoping uh we can have a another good
year for tazzy and um yeah really
appreciate you coming on the podcast
mate no worries mate thanks for thanks
for the invite and and likewise back at
you with the podcast mate and really
enjoying uh the stuff the work you are
doing and it's awesome to be in a
coaching team with you this year looking
forward to it how good and if you are
listening remember use the code what a
lad if you want twenty percent off at
the mad butcher go get amongst that love
your work